[Music]
pastor james coats was arrested and sent
to prison a couple of weeks ago in
canada what did he do he held a church
service
coates was denied bail apparently he is
set to be released soon he is still
facing at least one charge his wife
aaron said he had a very tough time in
jail he was placed in a two-week
quarantine only allowed to leave the
cell twice for 15 minutes each time
it's a shocking story we spoke to erin
coats earlier about her husband's case
here's what she told us this coach
thanks very much
for coming on it's hard to believe it's
shocking really
that your husband is in jail first how's
he doing
well he's in prison he's facing all the
regular things you would face there
uh trouble with food and um
you know i don't even really know what
to say how is he doing
he is he's a shepherd he's a he's a
bible teacher he's a theologian he's not
able to shepherd the people that he
loves he's not able to
challenge his mind he's not able to
serve in the way that he loves to serve
people so
this is this is hard on him a grown man
sitting in prison for preaching
a sermon this is such obvious tyranny
that i've got to ask
have any authorities in canada come to
your help i mean this is the ruling of
one judge but you have a lot of
politicians in alberta
or any of them coming to the rescue
sure i think that there's actually mps
and some mlas behind the scenes that are
are trying to help us but other than
that i think their hands are tied
you are are you canadian i am canadian
yes
so you grew up in the country do you
recognize it now
no i don't this is definitely not the
nation that i
grew up in what do you think what do you
think happened
well i think there's been a we're like a
boiling frog for a while i think
our freedoms have just been slowly
stripped from us and
and and so slowly over time that we
didn't even realize it and so when
something like
a health order is put in place that
takes away
your freedoms it's not shocking to
people and it really should be shocking
to people that there is a pastor in jail
right now
who's given his life to sacrifice and
love other people
to worship god that that's not shocking
to a lot of people and it really should
be we are on a dangerous
road right now and i think because we've
just been in the pot for so long
boiling that people aren't really
realizing the danger that we're facing
as a nation
throughout the united states we've seen
christian ministers harassed
because they are christian ministers and
therefore
disobedient they serve a higher power
you haven't seen this happen to people
who run abortion clinics or strip bars
or marijuana dispensaries
do you believe that's in this country do
you believe your husband was singled out
because he's a christian pastor
well i have to believe that the enemy is
singling him out we have a real enemy
who really hates the lord jesus christ
and really hates the blood
body that he purchased on the cross and
has given new life
to um yes we have an absolute real enemy
and he uses people to target the
ministers of god we know that through
scripture we know that through church
history
and so i really believe that they are
being targeted in our country
i think a lot of people watching this
who would have maybe dismissed what you
just said a year ago or now maybe taking
it a little bit more seriously
i appreciate your coming on your husband
is blessed to have a wife like you thank
you
thank you tucker